if you want an excuse to play the  amnesia games again I've got some good  news I'm Tony and this is your  terrifying gamespot news update the  amnesia series is coming to ps4 as a  three-game bundle first up is the  original amnesia the dark descent by  frictional games second is amnesia a  machine for pigs by the Chinese room and  last is the shorter spin-off game  amnesia Justine which is more like a  series of trials similar to the saw  movies no price was mentioned for the  bundle and it's unclear whether the  games will be available on disk or  digital-only the amnesia games are  coming to ps4 on November 22nd so not  quite in time for Halloween but if  you've never played the series this  seems like a good option and since we  scored the first two games in 8.5 and an  8 out of 10 respectively we can say  they're worth checking out to keep up  with all the scariest video game news  you're already in the right place  you